I think it's a day by day Moment by
moment
um challenge to be present you know to
be really present with somebody to
listen to somebody for us to survive for
us to thrive parts of our Lives just
have to be connected and on a really
authentic level you know the only thing
I know is love you know that's the thing
that always comes back to me the only
thing I know is really the love I have
for my family for my friends for nature
for music for people who I admire and
that's sort of the uncertainty for me
and I really don't have the answers but
I try and go into the day every day I
really do with with that in mind knowing
that I'll get through knowing that I'll
find a way having hope with that which a
lot of kids struggle with of course and
when I do that when I overcome my fears
or my doubts or my overthinking or
everything else I mean it always works
it always seems to give me a
energizes me in a way that I that makes
me feel good